we're gonna call this what dumpling Ding
Dongs we're not calling it Dublin call
this dumpling dingdong now three two one
ding-dong
live and direct from Hollywood but back
out of the kids we try to find the best
dumplings the best soup dumplings in all
of Los Angeles we're gonna play dumpling
telephone where we go to different
dumpling houses and it asked them where
they like to eat dumpling and that'll
lead us to another restaurant until we
ourselves are giant soup dumplings I'm
expecting to be really full cuz I'm a
monster
aah I've never really had a dumpling I
don't really know what to expect but I'm
starving and I'm stoked and Steven is
gonna be our kind of sordid rubric oh I
don't have a rubric broth dough a nice
the pleats look meat tenderness there's
one obvious choice that we should go to
from the mecca and end that we're late
Vegas we're going to playschool place
called inside phone so this is the first
stop on the dumpling ding-dong adventure
dumpling telephone use money beverages
pretty I get read Bobo I'm not you know
what was one of my favorite things
they're like individual little like
testicles in the mouth it's ridiculous
oh not testicles I'm scared just go with
it
let it flow let it happen well I what's
the purpose of evening I like to eat
okay all right it's a story so here we
have our sauces this is going to be a
health food vinegar and a soy sauce
normally we recommend for an optimal
taste it's gonna be three parts vinegar
and one part soy sauce we should
definitely compare the pork between
different establishes that's not the
possible standard suzhou standard -
don't play
whoa it's like a little baby mini soup
in one bite need civilians many people
do different things I just take a little
nibble outside pour out the soup drink
it and eat the dumpling up
nobody idea how you like let's see I'll
do I'm gonna use Steve's bite a hole in
it method which I'm very suspect up d
juicing the soup dumpling dipping in the
VIN only means such a fun activity for
the soup is just so good it's so good
the skin thinness allows me to really
enjoy the meat for the etapa dumplings I
do recommend that you cleanse your
palate first and then don't use any
dipping puffs for it I think I'm a fool
okay okay here it is I'm so happy
Oh Harrison you're up okay bye it's
crazy that this is a real food that was
like an out-of-body experience there you
mommy I felt like a new Hobbit putting
that in mind yeah definitely but those
Steve no Stephanie what is that's heaven
or anyway look definitely see where we
go from here guys these iPhone is like
the obvious choice but if you were
naughty to buildings here where would
you eat it's probably gonna have to be
mama Lu's what kind of occasion sends
you to mama Lu's
like when do you go when the line is too
long okay so the next part we're headed
to is called mama Lu's mama Lu's get it
dumped like eat it do whatever you want
in Tai Fung is like come here eat the
dumpling get out more people need
dumplings
so here they call them juicy pork
dumplings which i think is a better name
I think this dumpling better call me
American but I would like a larger meat
quantity we wanted my fried coconut buns
so I look at you
it's gotten all over your face this is
what you want it Collins at the beach
boy I didn't order it they just gave it
to us
so much meat Chinese people have
mastered the are not bunch a little
couple things about the art of buns
depends on what kind of buns we're
talking about again what do you not ever
order this but they just put it on the
house spicy one time my favorite the
spicy wonton is unreal
they started just like printing out oh
my god
I think the mama Lu's people know what
our game is and they don't want us to go
to another place they're trying to just
shut us down by giving us waiting you
too much food already just feel a little
heavier more meats perhaps Cheers
beast mode hunger squad mama Lu's as in
be just like the environment in fact
that they really want to take care of
meteor more wholesome that's the den
type [ __ ] this is mama Liu the police
are very pretty awesome we ordered three
things and look what they gave us today
I'm coming around on these dumplings I
think I'd prefer them to Jin type dog I
like the broth but I prefer it comes
down to your broth preference I like
absolutely love being type own but I
think this is my new go-to spot I
thought both places we at today had
great dumplings and that was the problem
is that I ate too many dumplings at
those spots ready okay
no but yes we can't go on way too much
god bless you soup dumplings be small
hunger squad strikes again I know how
much good quality Chinese food and
dumplings needed even so to go on this
journey with him and many more Freddie
is fully unresponsive boy I am still
sweaty this is not as easy as it looks
people yeah eat and be merry it's not
fun eating all this food we take this
bullet for the viewers at home so that
you don't have to you're welcome yeah
exactly
you know no apologies